hey Richard uh first and foremost thank
you for your work uh I've been watching
you since 2020 and read your book so I
would you leave a nice review on Amazon
for me on the book I always gotta ask
thank you I did man yeah thank you for
pleas do so guys if youve read the book
always go to Amazon and leave a kind
review thank you sorry Leo go ahead so I
was dating a single mom uh she have 12y
old she's 31 I am 31 I work in AOS space
and defense I'm an engineer we both
lived in La so she went to nursing
school and as soon as she graduates
right gets her first big girl job you
know she gets a coworker uh I didn't
find out until she manipulated me and I
had to break up with her uh so it's been
five months but I have been having a
little bit hard time getting over the
five-year relationship uh what did she
do she step out on you did she go and
betray you and bang somebody else uh I
didn't know if she banged somebody
before breaking up but definitely after
like within days oh yeah something was
going on before then yeah okay so how
did you lose out to this guy like what
did he what did he have to offer because
you know women only leave a relationship
if she thinks that she's going to do
better I'm not sure this guy is a nurse
uh he's shorter than her she makes oh
she works with them yeah she works with
them isn't that convenient
yeah so uh I've been having hard time
because if I look at myself I'm
definitely better than this guy he's
even younger so you know a lot of the
times Leo women when they're with you
for a while will start to take you for
granted they will form this idea in
their head that any guy that they leave
you for will be at your level or better
quite easily and it's not always always
true in fact it's usually not true
especially well look I mean if you're a
10 out of 10 and you're a solid chap
like a top shelf guy in the top 1% the
chances of her replacing you is slim to
none you said you work in Aerospace yes
you get paid well into six figures yes
yeah goodlooking guy in shape broad
shoulders nrow waist broad shoulder nrow
waist I'm 510 um I would give my looks
about seven MH you're you're in a a
higher percentage of men out there if
you're making over six figures you said
you're 28 or was it 31 sorry I'm 31 31
yeah if you're 31 making well into six
figures like you're like you're coming
into your stride now and dude like at
the end of the day this chick was 31
with a 12-y old that meant she had a kid
when she was a teenager yeah she had a
kid with a guy who was 10 years older
than her and she's her she's his third
baby mama she's his third baby mama okay
yeah well he's doing a good job at
scattering his his seed isn't he yeah so
I was cool enough to be in this
relationship long enough yeah uh because
she kind of kept me into it but when I
once I realized it's time did you go
through beta
tization I didn't actually I was
actually pretty dominant in the
relationship with frame okay with frame
and she couldn't break it she tried
breaking it many times and she tried to
get a ring and I was like let's wait
let's see how it goes and she couldn't
wait yeah you know man you know here's
the thing because we've
all every guy is going to deal with some
level of heartbreak where they commit to
a Woman They ego invests in her even a
child that isn't theirs that they'll
that they'll take care of and protect
and provide for uh you form a
relationship a strong bond with her and
even her kid um and they don't like
things don't last forever you know you
know I did a show the other week about
uh cheating versus betrayal and the non-
monogamous uh like fashion in which we
operate as human beings we're not very
good at it you know we suck at it so
like you can't expect like one of the
big red red pilling moments for a lot of
guys you know when they unplug is like
they realize she wasn't mine it was just
my turn you know or some sandai to that
effect that we've all heard before um
they've said that if you date somebody
for Years it'll probably take you five
years for for them to be completely out
of your head right I've seen guys suffer
for six months 12 months year and a half
you know in some cases with women that
they've spent you know some time with
it's normal to feel betrayed it like
anger is a legitimate response in the
shape like in the form of an injustice
she steps out on you after you commit to
her and raise her kid and you know
provide for them minut it sounded like
you put her through school as well yes I
did and and you put her through school I
mean you put her through school into a
job where she met a guy that she left
you for this is like you know like this
is the story that I've heard as old as
time I was talking to a friend of mine
the other day and he was telling me his
wife stepped out on him and I was like
well what the [__] happened you you know
we all thought that you guys were good
he goes yeah well she liked horses and
because she liked horses I bought her a
horse and I thought you know that was a
good thing to do because that's what a
good husband does he you know he makes
money and provides only she started
banging the stable boy at you know
wherever she was riding the horses um
you know this is a story as you know as
old the time is you're going to you're
going to do things and you're going to
offer Solutions and remedies and
economic benefits to women that they're
going to use to betray you um get used
to it it's funny that said that about
the uh horse story so because I'm very
dedicated to my work I travel out of
state uh two weeks out of the month yeah
so uh I gave her opportunity to control
the house however she needed to and she
did that pretty well when it was time
but as soon as she steps out like she
gets her first job uh everything changes
around her yeah and uh she couldn't
break my frame she tried breaking it at
the last day when she came to you know
get her stuff I just wanted to ask her
like hey why did you pull this move and
her answer was you didn't call me
beautiful
[Laughter]
enough and I started laughing at her
face I'm like really okay that's that's
that's hilarious that's that's some
[__] right there that's that's the
other guy calling her beautiful and she
just figured you know what I'll use this
on him I got to tell him something
because I'm a hoe and I gotta make up
some reason so I'm gonna blame it on him
and say that he didn't say that I was
beautiful enough it's not your fault if
she's a hoe hoes are gonna hoe you can't
make a hoe a housewife you know you got
involved with a gal that had a
12-year-old that she you know birthed
when she was what 18 she got it from a
10 a guy that was 10 years older than
her she ended up being the third bab of
Mama she's an idiot right and you must
have seen the red flags in hindsight now
that you've read my book you know what
they are now um you know that she's not
a high quality woman she's of high
virtue so just consider it a five-year
lesson or whatever the you know
relationship term happened to be a
five-year lesson that cost you five
years of your life you know five years
of investment uh that you've now taken
from and you're going to move on from
you're going to leave it behind move
onwards and upwards the next scal that
you find is going to be hotter younger
with no kids tighter all that stuff I
guarantee and you're going to look back
on this call one day you're going to go
and watch it and be like what the [__]
was I thinking why did I even care so
you will get past it there is no doubt
in my mind that you will it's just that
you're going through some grief right
now and it's fine focus on things that
you give a [__] about I mean like
whatever your hobbies are that you might
have put off because you were dealing
with her or her priorities or her kids
priorities all of those interests that
you might have had that you may have put
off double down and spend some time on
them man you know things that you'd like
to explore places that you know that you
wanted to visit trips that you may have
wanted to take that she wouldn't let you
take because whatever reason go do them
right yeah and one thing I wanted to put
uh for the guys out there that she tried
to convince me very hard that she even
changed her religion to Islam and also
went out and got a tattoo of my name in
her ring finger oh okay and at that
moment I realized she trying too hard so
I'm going to put it off I kept my frame
I didn't let it break I didn't go and
give her a finger and you know bend down
in my knees so so she wasn't Muslim what
was her background uh she's white she's
from California Los Angeles okay and
you're from Islam right yeah uh my
parents I mean uh my family came from
Iran what did your parents think of you
hooking up with a g with a kid from a
prior
relationship I mean they didn't like it
at the first place but she kind of
played it pretty well so I used to take
my mother to the mosque nearby and she
showed up and uh converted to Islam in
front of her you know without even
telling me so it was a whole show you
know what it sounds like to me like you
probably didn't move at the speed that
she wanted you to you know she she went
and got the tattoo she went and
converted to your religion she had
genuine burning desire for you you had
good frame I bet what it was was that
because she was pushing for something
that you weren't willing to give her she
started to look elsewhere because she
knew that her chips were were getting
cashed out cuz she's 31 man she's
getting older right yeah and that's fine
because you didn't want to give it to
her probably because you like your
intuition was going off going like ah
let's wait and see I'm not really
digging this I don't know if this is a
good idea right right so the intuition
uh that I had was she left her baby's
father uh telling me that he was abusive
quote unquote abusive uh but when I look
at the guy every single chick dude every
single chick that leaves a guy always
has some story about he was abusive he
was financially abusive you know what
that translates to he set a budget and
he didn't want me to go outside of it
but she'll call him financially abusive
or some [__] right don't but the baby's
father actually take care of the kid
more than her she's always in school
she's outside she go and she's always uh
using him as a tool to keep the kid yeah
yeah so look man like you saw what she
was made of that's it you you know you
spent five years of your life and you
got an exit now she's somebody else's
problem consider it a blessing
considered a massive blessing I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clip's
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line book and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out